happiness is miserable second claim is
we don't really know what makes us happy
but we think we do two really bad things
to go together
so some of you who are here three years
ago remember this slide this slide is
work by Dannic based on research by
Danny Kahneman Tim Wilson and Dan
Gilbert and others and what it does is
it pulls apart what we think correlates
with happiness versus what really
correlates with happiness and and it's
also anchored by things that are more
glamorous versus mundane so the way to
read this chart is on this left side it
matters less than you think so most
people think that intelligence or beauty
or youth actually correlates with
happiness but it does far less than
people think and again this makes sense
right so you get you're under wrap and
you're so happy for three days and then
you watch your graduate degree and then
you get your graduate degree and you
were so happy for three days and then
you want to get a PhD and then you get
your PhD and you were so happy but you
really want that good job right and so
it keeps going on and on until you're in
the left tail of that bell curve way
over here until you've got a totally
distorted perspective of where you are
and what it takes to get happy youth one
of the most robust findings work done by
Laura Carstensen and her colleagues here
out of Stanford shows that as as
individuals get older they get more
happy now work that I do with septum
Barr and also Cassie McGill der shows
that the type of happiness also changes
over the life course and I'll get to
that later
the research is very mixed but in
general there is a threshold over which
more money doesn't bring greater
happiness and you've seen this research
some people say it's 40,000 a year in
California it's 100,000 so you all have
much more to go or move out of the state
either one but there's so there's
there's thresholds and and again there's
a decreasing return on that incremental
dollar but the thing I wanted to focus
on here today is that right-hand
quadrant in a mundane matters more than
you think space and I'd like to talk and
free time again isn't you got fired
you've got a lot of free time it's the
perception that you can control your
time so
it's not can you control your time it's
the perception that you can control your
time which is why academics is so great
but what I wanted to harp on is
volunteering now volunteering is pretty
interesting
first of all too bad brand name we're
working to change this name Obama I
think has done a good job in making
small dent in this area valuing service
and will probably hopefully continue on
but one of the things that's most most
robust in this research is that people
who give time and money report greater
well-being and happiness and those who
have greater well-being and Happiness
report giving more time and money so
it's a bi-directional relationship which
feeds on itself right so you're more
giving to others you're happier vice
versa now this is a pretty robust
finding and you've probably seen it but
what's so interesting is the research so
this is some work done by Mike Norton
out of Harvard and some of his
colleagues and what they do is they
create four conditions and so you guys
are going to be in the first condition
you're gonna get all five dollars today
not really so don't get excited but
pretend that you got five dollars and
I'm gonna ask you to spend it on
something personal so you're probably
gonna spend it on some expense or some
gift for yourself so just you're gonna
be personal you're gonna spend it on
something pro-social so something for
someone else you could again give it to
charity give it their friend buy a
Starbucks gift certificate it's not
specified you're gonna get their same
conditions but I'm gonna give you $20
each and now I'm going to ask you which
condition do you think will make you
happier so how many people think the
five-dollar person will spend will make
you happiest five-dollar pro-social
spend $20 personal $20 pro-social you're
all wrong that's awesome
so what happens
what happens here is that to everyone
thinks that the $20 I can spend it on
myself if I want will make them the
happiest and again it's not just this
one experiment there's a lot of
experiments to back this up now everyone
assumes 20 is better than five so this
group is clearly gonna be happier than
this group and they do think that the
personal spend is gonna make them
happier than the pro-social spend when
I'm forcing you to spend it on someone
else
now these researchers do another study
and what they do is they create four
conditions and now they actually give
you five dollars five dollars twenty
eight twenty and then they say the next
day how happy are you and they find time
one versus time two so I'm gonna measure
all of you before I give you the money
and then after I give you the money and
the way to read this graph is on the
left hand side is the five dollars the
yellow bars are not significantly
different than zeros these are
individuals that were asked to spend
money on themselves and they got a
little bit less than half a little less
happy so it's not significant so don't
read into it what's much more important
is that what was significant are the two
conditions and it didn't matter if you
got twenty dollars or if you got five
dollars the people in the give this to
someone else condition report it being
happier two days later and again this is
the same subject pool that came not the
same people with the same subject pool
that came and just in the prior
experiment said that that's not how what
would actually make me happy and there's
a lot of empirical evidence to suggest
that what we think brings us happiness
does not in fact